mokhtar on va mettre la musique de
deutsch et dance et attention tu vas
faire le porte et fait attention à ça je
vais te dire les gens les gens est miné
sreg si il y à n'importe quel accident
je te le dis qu'est ce qui t'arrive l'a
dit hier je sais que tu adoptés portent
les noms comme ça tu vois parfois ah oui
et toi que tu vas faire tu crois
vraiment que tu vas tu aura pas
d'accident et sur ses gaffes à ta gueule
ce lien sinon je suis moi j va y aller à
fond vraiment d'accord vatican même
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
chez vous
reste
les mecs à dieu s'il vous plaît est ce
qu'il faut savoir à quoi sert ce à la
boîte happy cafetiers rien dedans déjà
ça de l'autre il un talkie walkie sont à
tête de ma mère on dirait qu'il est le
président des états unis
merde ça nous là là à me lâcher les
bordels vous me lâcher ça sert à quoi ça
va ça va parler la samarie pour parler
aux collègues qui sont protégés à parler
aux collègues ton protéger deux autres
merci bravo pour elle si les autres s'en
fout mais pas moi au centre auto suri
n'est que mon chéri concentreront sur
inès attention 2
so music with et 14 3 2 ap
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
non
alors là
anthony robin plus de rester kevin donc
c'est le mec d'inès kevin le fils et le
mari d'inès
non non non
regardez les gardes
[Musique]